foreign
let's go to the phones let's just get
right to it let's go to Renee in Falling
Waters West Virginia I'm glad it's not
Rising Waters West Virginia how are you
Renee
I'm fantastic how are you good that
would not be good if it was Rising
Waters all right so what's up
all right so
so question how can I train myself to
not catastrophize everything that I am
not in control of Renee that's one of my
favorite things to do why would you want
to give that up exhausting I'm so good I
know but it's so fun it's so fun what if
I know but what if like what if that's
like the haunt question right right all
right what are you catastrophize why do
you do that
well
what I think it stems from we'll give
you a little background when I was five
years old
um I was in a vehicle accident that
killed my mom
and from that point Renee why didn't you
start there
I'm not laughing at your mom passed away
I was laughing I think I found it uh
right I think this is this is the thing
so
yeah I mean it's everything so in car
rides I can be in a parking lot going
five miles an hour and I know in my mind
that is logical if I get in an accident
going five miles an hour it's fine but
in my insane brain I picture
fatalities and fire and explosions
um you know I'm afraid of turning my
phone off because I'm convinced as soon
as I do it something's gonna happen in
my family someone would be trying to get
a hold of me and they'll be a big thing
when my daughter goes with her father
I'm convinced she's going to get
kidnapped or they'll be in an accident
or something will happen then I'm not
there to control or keep from happening
um
yeah like things like that so I want you
to reframe this this is not your crazy
brain
this is your ride on bin there brain
right
this is your brain doing the best job it
can to keep you safe
and good for it
good for it and here's a weird thing
about it you know what it feels like
it's kept you from dying in a car wreck
for the last 25 years
so far so as far as it's concerned it's
done its job
right right and then the
the spin up part of your brain is like
so far but it could be today
and here's here's here is the the
damning loop that you're in
you're right
your daughter could get kidnapped
that could actually happen
you could actually get in a fiery
burning car wreck do you think that's
gonna happen
logically
logically no yep right so the magic is
how do we get to yeah that could happen
but probably not
and the the sentence that that little
phrase has was part of my getting well
journey and I still is with me now
which is or not my journey and it sounds
like I'm some like on some spiritual
Voodoo one but like on the adventure
from going from a super anxious over
catastrophizer to how do I just be a
like a well-adjusted joyful dad
co-worker and friend and husband
is the sentence but probably not and I
got that from a banker I didn't get that
from a therapist I got it from my
buddies a banker and I was like yeah
what about this and he goes oh okay that
could happen and he goes but probably
not and I realized oh yeah I'm just
staring at this one little sliver of pie
and I'm forgetting all the other pile
around it
um
have you
gone and done something like EMDR
no
I think you should
okay and this is not me telling you this
clinically this is me telling you as a
friend
what you have yet to do is metabolize
the trauma that you experienced
firsthand and by the way it's not just
that car wreck it's your body's memory
of
being a tethered tether-free
five-year-old kid without a mom
and it's easy to put all of this onto
Vehicles onto CarX but it's way bigger
than that
the trauma here is way bigger than that
the trauma is a little five-year-old
girl that was stumbling through the
world saying
but where's my mom
right and your body has to be able to
have that memory and ask that question
and have that thought and not take off
on you as though the wreck is happening
again
yeah does that make sense it does so
healing here is not that your mom comes
back healing here isn't that you didn't
experience the single most horrific
thing a child could experience which is
the death of their mother
being in it and horrific one second
you're here one second she's gone
healing is I can remember that I can
think of that and my body knows I'm safe
in the present and that's what something
like EMDR can do a good therapist can
help you with that we're just trying to
make peace with
the present we weren't safe then but
we're safe now and then here's the worst
part that's the worst part about
catastrophizing the only way to heal
from it is right through it
right that's the worst it's the worst
it's the worst the only way to get over
a phobia is to hold a snake and realize
it's not going to kill you it could it
might but it probably won't I probably
will
and here did you hear how flipping I am
about it and now it's just become second
nature right my wife is four minutes
late she could be cheating on me yep but
she's probably not you know I mean right
um so it's now it's just a it's just an
automated it's an automated statement in
my mind
um here's the place I want you to start
number one I want you to get how old are
you
32 32 okay so I want you to call a
counselor who specializes in EMDR try
there start there in your local area
um and you may have to travel a little
bit this isn't something I don't think
you can do EMDR I've never heard of it
being done uh on
uh
uh like Zoom or something right
um but I want you to find a counselor in
your area that can do it okay
um and say I was a part of a
catastrophic wreck as a kid and I am
continuing to replay that
um it sounded like tell me if I'm wrong
it sounded like just when I was talking
about a little five-year-old girl
missing her mom your body started you
got choked up there
oh absolutely okay that's what we're
looking for okay
that's where the that's the the center
that's the engine of the catastrophizing
is your body still thinks it has it can
do a thing that will keep your mom okay
your body still thinks okay mom's gone
we are on our own
and the way through our own uh the way
through this is we will control
everything and when your brain feels
like you're not paying enough attention
it's gonna start playing movies in the
foreground to make you pay attention
yes and we're just going to turn that
that part of your brain off and let it
be where it should be which is
identifying real threats not ones that
are imagined
the second thing I want you to do is I'm
holding this up if you're watching this
on YouTube
uh it's just get a journal of some sort
something small that you can write down
the wildest of the wild thoughts
okay okay and sometimes I I do it much
less
um now but occasionally I do it I'll
hold them at arm's length so I can look
at them
and I just ask myself one question is
this true
and 99.9 of the time it's it might be
but probably not
right
and there's going to be real threats in
the world
right like right now Everything feels
like 1917.
a small little conflict started over and
you know in Russia and then last night
or two nights ago Putin mobilizes a
bunch of troops and then somebody has a
failed assassination over it feels like
the world's turning into a powder keg
and we're waiting on one spark to set it
off right yeah
um
so There's real stuff
but I want my body to be able to focus
through the noise at those things the
things I can actually they're actually
real threats and by the way what I can
actually do about them that's the other
part that's that's part two identifying
those thoughts is this true and then
underneath it what can I do about it
that's what we're gonna Focus you know
what I can do about Russia invading
Ukraine is apps zero things I can do
zero things
yeah
zero zero zero zero
that makes sense it does yes I wish I
could give you a thing that just stopped
it
right but it's actually not a bug in the
system it's your brain trying to take
care of you
what's your biggest let's say let's do
this one together what's your biggest
catastrophe
what's the thing you catastrophize the
most
uh something happening to my kids
and me not being there it could be
anything
oh your body's you've been through that
story
yeah
it it was hellacious not having your mom
wasn't it
oh yes
something could happen to you but it
probably won't
right
so what can you do about it
and that's that's an honest question and
I'm thinking like not texting and
driving and wearing a seatbelt and
not drinking and drag what are some
things you can do about it
troll
the more specific you can itemize things
the more your
um The Fear Part of your brain will
realize you're driving
meaning if for a season you have a
little note card in your car that just
says have I done all the things yep yep
I've done what I can do
okay you can't do anything about a drunk
driver
right you can't do anything about
somebody running a red light
you can make sure your seat belts on you
can make sure you're not intoxicated you
make sure I don't text and drive
make sure all my kids are in uh their
car seats and then that's what I can do
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice Making Peace there but
if you're in the car driving and you're
wondering did I do everything I could do
do I do everything and now your brain's
like who's driving and then out of the
back of your brain I'll take over and
then the story start right yeah
so what can I actually do in a nuclear
Holocaust not not a lot you know I mean
not a lot yeah
um I I'll have some canned goods I guess
and there's a local there's a creek down
the street from me I'll go there right I
mean so it's like very limited and it's
like okay so not a lot right
and uh
just making peace with it are you scared
to go back and deal with it
uh no I don't think so all right let me
see it like this
not that you're scared like I don't know
what to do uh more like I'm scared that
if I finally deal with this Mom leaves
all right
let me tell you what's on the other side
of this thing
you haven't laughed for real in a long
time
foreign
and you probably Renee haven't slept
in full crash course deep REM sleep and
beneath that the deep sleep
prob possibly ever
you haven't been able to prop your feet
up in a relationship and just settle in
you might be married and be in love and
he loves you or whatever but
to be completely at peace because you've
been making sure nobody comes busting in
the door to kill everybody
that's what we're aiming for here
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it